Saying that a story has a beginning, a
middle, and an end is a useless piece
of information that does nothing to
describe a story, and more importantly,
it does nothing to help you tell a story.
When people tell you that stories
have beginnings, middles, and
endings, it is some of the worst
possible advice they can give you.
If you're hoping to tell better
stories, let me tell you why.
The reason why this is terrible advice
is because everything in the world
has a beginning, middle, and end.
This morning I got dressed.
It had a beginning, a middle, and an end.
I started with my underwear.
That was the beginning.
Then I put on a shirt and a pair
of pants that was the middle,
and then shoes and socks.
That was the end.
Does it help people get dressed to know
it has a beginning, a middle, and an end.
No, it doesn't help in any way whatsoever.
Everything has a beginning,
a middle, and an end.
A Snickers bar has a beginning,
It has a beginning.
I open it up.
I take a bite.
Oh, it is okay.
You're not the best
Snickers bar in the world.
Stories should have great beginnings.
Better than this one, by the way.
Eventually I would get to the middle.
The middle is no good either.
And then eventually I
would get to the end.
The end.
Oh, a really bad snookers bar.
Most are good.
I think it's 'cause it's so cold.
It's probably the gas.
Station that doesn't help you make a
Snickers bar, doesn't it help you even
understand what a Snickers bar is?
Everything has a beginning,
a middle, and an end.
My life, as much as I don't
want to admit to, it has a
beginning, a middle, and an end.
I was born, I don't remember it, but
I was born and that was the beginning.
I'm now somewhere in the
middle, and then theoretically,
hopefully not, but possibly.
So someday there will be an end.
That doesn't define a life
that doesn't even help you
understand how to live a life.
Saying that a story has a beginning, a
middle, and an end is a useless piece
of information that does nothing to
describe a story, and more importantly,
it does nothing to help you tell a story,
a story.
Is not a beginning, a middle, and an end.
A story is a singular moment in your
life in which something changed.
You thought about the
world in a different way.
You thought about yourself
in a different way.
You changed fundamentally
as a human being.
A singular moment in time that is
wrapped around the context that
brings that singular moment to
the greatest clarity possible.
One moment in time, what I
call a five second moment.
'cause these changes
happen instantaneously.
A five second moment with the context
dropped around it to make that five
second moment as clear as possible to
the audience that you're speaking to.
That is what a story is, a singular moment
in time where something changed about
you or your perception of the world.
And the context that you wrap around
that moment to bring it to the greatest
clarity possible to your audience.
And that is every single movie you've
ever seen, every TV show you've ever
watched, every book you've ever read, any
play or musical you've seen on the stage,
and any story that I have ever told.
If it doesn't have a five second
moment of transformation, it's not bad.
It's just called an anecdote.
It's just a moment in
time that is amusing and.
Silly and delightful, but doesn't have
the stickiness, the unforgettable ness,
the staying power, the connectiveness,
the relatability of an actual story.
They're not bad.
They just have to understand.
They don't have the
power of an actual story.
So when you're thinking about
storytelling and you're thinking
about, I'm gonna craft a story.
I'm gonna produce a great story
for the screen or the stage,
or maybe just on my first date.
The last thing you should think
about, the very, very last thing
you should think about is it needs
a beginning, a middle, and an end.
Because no matter what you say, no
matter what the length of the thing
you say is, it will always inherently
have a beginning, a middle, and an end.
But does that help you in any way?
It doesn't.
Everything has a beginning, a
middle, and an end, so it is
stupid, meaningless advice.
For crafting better stories.
Instead, find a moment.
Find a moment that means
something to you in this world.
Wrap the context around that moment
to bring clarity so that the audience
understands what you're saying and then
deliver it in the best possible way.
That is the way to tell a great story.